uh looks like the college application
isn't the only
thing that's problematic hey everyone
i'm abby sharp welcome to abby's kitchen
today's video is sponsored by buildbar
and we'll be looking at
controversial fashion blogger and
daughter of convicted felon
lori lachlan olivia jade but first let
me tell you about my sponsor build bar
so
if you're new here welcome i hope you
like the show
but if you're a regular viewer you know
i'm a fan
of these bars they taste like a
chocolate bar
and to me they're like a really easy
convenient source of protein
for super busy days and that to me is
kind of a rarity when i think that most
protein bars
kind of taste like crap so today i am
super excited because
so many of you have dmed me and told me
that i absolutely
need to try the dark chocolate cookie
dough
and it came and i'm really really pumped
so
let's try her out
i'm so pumped i'm so pumped all right
well this one's got 15 grams of protein
it's got cookie dough inside
i'll have what she's having that is so
good now
these are a lower sugar bar for those
you looking for something like that
but if i were to have this as like a
post-workout snack
i probably want to pair it with some
fruit oatmeal or some toast
so if you want to give these bars a try
check out the link in the description
and use my promo code for 15 off of your
order
also you can pause the screen or check
out my description for a quick
disclaimer
including a trigger warning to those
with past
or current experiences with disordered
eating
i will be talking about calories and
macros
so of course feel free to skip the stats
portion of this video
if that's not supportive to you and your
journey
okay lovers well if you are not familiar
with olivia jade
gianouli she's a 21 year old youtuber
and daughter to actress laurie lachlan
and fashion designer massimo
most significantly however she was made
infamous for her
fraudulent acceptance to the university
of southern california
as part of a college admission bribery
scandal
that landed both her parents in jail
there's actually a new documentary on
netflix that looks at the college
admissions scandal as a whole
if you want to get caught up on all the
juicy details
but anyway after that situation came to
light she
understandably disappeared from youtube
for a little while
and basically the media painted her as
the poster child
of white privilege she herself has
admitted that she never really even saw
a problem with what went down
simply because she was so engrossed in
her own
privileged reality but i'm not here to
debate the ethics of admissions fraud or
her taking the position of a more
qualified
but perhaps less privileged college
candidate
i am not even going to get into
hollywood white privilege in education
because
this video would be hours long
today i'm going to stick to the food
i'ma try to put
my salty unflattering bites aside
pull up my big girl professional panties
and
get into the goods let's do it it's just
ezekiel bread you need an avocado
it worked olive oil oil
everything but the bagel seasoning she
is crispy
well i do it's pretty simple
okay so this looks familiar i think we
can call this
the breakfast of lifestyle youtubers
pandemic edition
and i mean i'm also totally guilty of
loving everything bagel
avocado toast too so i am 100
part of this joke here but honestly
there's a reason why this combo is just
so popular
it really does taste great and it's
inherently really balanced
so we've got fiber and healthy fats in
the avocado
protein and fat in the egg and
fiber-rich carbs in the bread
and actually in the case of olivia's
choice of bread we've also got a solid
amount of protein from the sprouted soy
beans
lentils and whole grains there's
definitely a lot of interest
in spreaded breads right now because
they're typically higher in fiber and
protein
and lower in gluten anti-nutrients and
also the glycemic index
and that's because spreading grains
actually helps to
partially break down the starches which
actually
lowers the available carb content and as
a result
the glycemic index of the bread it also
increases the protein and fiber content
with one study finding that sprouting
brown rice for about
four days increased its fiber content by
13 spreaded grains are also higher
nutrients like vitamin c
e folate beta-carotene and b vitamins
and sprouting also helps to reduce some
of the anti-nutrients
that inhibit nutrient absorption for
example
research suggests that spreading grains
and legumes reduces their phytic acid
content
by up to 50 percent which in turn may
help to increase
iron absorption finally there's also
evidence that spreaded grains
may be easier to digest because the
sprouting process
acts as an act of pre-digestion
so if you like spreaded grain bread i
think it's a great option in general
and is a really awesome base for avocado
toast
let's see what's for lunch oh sad
discovery we
actually don't have any food yeah yeah
like none
wish you would have spoke up so i'm
gonna just snack on something because
i'm really hungry i'm gonna eat these
and then order a salad will you order me
a salad
sure okay so i often get asked if meal
planning is
incompatible with intuitive eating
absolutely not i think that meal
planning is actually a really great way
to save time
money and a lot of energy thinking about
food
and just because you have pre-plan some
recipes out for the week
doesn't mean that you're not honoring
your body intuitive eating doesn't
just mean eating whatever you feel like
in exactly
that moment it's ultimately about
self-care
and if planning your meals helps you
make sure that you have some nourishing
meals and foods at the ready to fuel
your energy and fill your belly
that's the intuitive way to go now where
it becomes
unintuitive is when following said meal
plan
starts to feel like a bit of a chore and
you develop
fear or anxiety around the idea of
eating something
not on that plan but i admire the fact
that olivia was able to be like
whoopsies i didn't plan this out i don't
even have any food in the house
so i'm just gonna eat some chips and
order something in i get that this is a
very privileged state to be in so again
don't think that intuitive eating
has to look like this but i'm just
saying that it's actually very
refreshing to me to see
a wedding a day that isn't elaborately
staged
and you need to know that 99 of what in
a day videos that you see
are probably at least somewhat staged
influencers generally want to show you
the highlight reel
or make their diet look more perfect
then
maybe it actually is ditto for pictures
that regular people share online of
their dinner or
their kids meals they're not showing you
the frozen tv dinner that they had the
night before
or the fact that their kid only ate the
bun off their plate
like mine sometimes does that's the
truth that's the real truth but anyways
back to snacking
i didn't know they were real vegetables
it's sweet potato first of all
i want to preface this comment with the
fact that
i love tara chips i really really do i
think that they are super flavorful
and have a light satisfying crunch that
i'm like totally obsessed with
but i also love classic lace or ruffles
so
yeah your girl doesn't discriminate when
it comes to chips but
yes they are definitely made of
real vegetables the same way that lays
or
ruffles are also actually made of real
potatoes
which are a vegetable i myself have
actually been to the farms here in
canada that grow
laced potatoes so i know but
are these gourmet chips healthier than
traditional potato chips
if you compare the nutrition content of
regular potato chips to
veggie chips you'll see that they have
virtually the same amount of calories
fat and saturated fat with the veggie
chips having
a little bit more fiber and a little
less salt than your classic
fried lays in other words these veggie
chips have what we call
a health halo they may be made with a
greater variety of root vegetables which
is great
but they're still deep fried salted
vegetables so
if you like veggie chips great if you
like potato chips
that's great too choose a crunchy snack
that you
actually like best savor it
and move on one doesn't need to be good
and the other one bad let's see what's
next
okay this is lunch i just got here it's
just a salad
and this is the dressing the dressing is
just olive oil and lemon this is the
only dressing i
even like just because i'm picky
okay so olivia's lunch looks like a
simple green salad with avocado celery
greens and some
lemon olive oil dressing and there looks
to be some
kind of bread on the side love that
we've got lots of veggies we've got
fiber rich carbs in the bread
and some healthy fats in here from the
avocado
and olive oil but there isn't a whole
lot
else and since we already had avocado at
breakfast
it would be ideal to switch it up there
also
isn't any protein here and since we only
really had
one egg and one slice of bread at
breakfast with
no real snacks in between other than
some chips i definitely
think we could bump that up as well now
i did see another one of her vlogs
where she had the same salad but with
chicken on top so
maybe this was just like an off protein
day
but i will say that the great thing
about a lot of these salad takeout
restaurants
is that it's super easy to add some kind
of protein to your greens whether
she was feeling like chicken or tofu
salmon
beans or whatever it really wouldn't be
that hard to bulk this
up and yes of course sometimes these
add-ons do cost more money but
i don't know i have a feeling that
that's not really an issue for olivia
let's see what else she has to say
they put so much in here and i had a lot
for practice while i acknowledge that
everyone's appetite
is different i did want to just touch
base on this comment
because i can imagine that a lot of
olivia's young fans
may hear her describe her one piece of
toast
and her veggie only salad as a lot of
food
and wonder what's up for most active
young women
olivia's age it's really not nope
i can appreciate that it might be a lot
of the same same greens here with the
salad since
there wasn't a whole lot else in that
bowl but
that's where we could maybe cut back on
the veg and
swap in some more calorie dense root
vegetables or protein or
whole grains in there that would allow
her to meet her nutrient needs
without dragging herself through a
container of like
just lettuce with some avocado on top if
the volume of food was kind of turning
her off and overwhelming her
but let's see what she's having for
[Music]
dinner
[Music]
split it open and see if it was cut this
looks super delicious
and i'm happy to see a solid source of
protein in this meal with the chicken
breast
and the chickpea pasta we've also got
some fiber
rich carbs in the pasta plus some fat in
the cheese
and the oil now obviously when you
google healthiest way to cook
deep frying isn't at the top of most
listicles and while i don't know what
kind of oil she's frying in
considering that her father is italian
i'm just gonna take a wild guess and
assume
that maybe it was olive oil and yes
contrary to popular belief you can
actually fry in olive oil it won't
automatically make the oil toxic
or poisonous or even rancid olive oil
actually has a pretty high smoke point
of between
390 and 468 fahrenheit
and since deep frying typically happens
between 350 and 375 fahrenheit
there isn't a concern about it breaking
down
even extra virgin olive oil smoke point
is 350 to 410
so it also might be okay at higher
cooking temperatures
when people talk about how heating
vegetable oils result in
toxic chemicals they're really referring
to the byproducts of
oxidation but since olive oil is rich in
antioxidants
it actually is more stable and produces
fewer oxidation byproducts compared to
other oils when heated
the bottom line is that there is no
evidence i'm aware of
of any damage to human health from
heating vegetable oils
like olive oil you might lose out on
some of the nuanced flavors in a really
good quality extra virgin olive oil
and you might slightly reduce the
antioxidant levels
but the heat doesn't automatically
render it
toxic or convert it to a trans fat
as a lot of people might think olive oil
or not if i were to put my public health
dietitian hat
on i probably wouldn't recommend deep
frying every night
i mean i personally rarely do it because
i feel like it stinks up my whole
house and my clothes for days but i also
have to still kind of give the girl
props
for having a seemingly uncomplicated
relationship with food
to do it the traditional way and not
feel the need to kind of like veganize
this or paleoize this or keto eyes this
or whatever
she's just making the dish taste good as
for the chickpea pasta you guys know
i'm a huge fan of the stuff i just think
it's a really easy way to sneak in more
fiber and protein
especially for carb-loving kids who
maybe aren't into
traditional sources of protein so we
could probably throw
a little spinach or saute in another
vegetable
just to balance this plate out a little
bit but in the context
of olivia's day with that bigger salad i
get that
maybe she's just kind of like veggieed
out and that totally makes sense to me
so what can we say about our girl
olivia's diet
let's take a look at the stats and of
course a trigger warning i'm about to
talk numbers so
feel free to skip ahead to this time
stamp if this feels triggering for you
so i had to make some estimations here
of course but
i guess that olivia's whole day clocked
in around 1500 to
1600 calories the vast majority of which
was coming from
that dinner meal her date also came in
as
pretty low carb high fat and on the
lower end of the recommended protein
range she was also low on most of her
micronutrients
but most notably for a young woman of
her age
calcium and iron and also there weren't
any major sources of omega-3s
in her diet so let me start by giving
the girl credit
where credit is due olivia seems to have
a
pretty laid-back approach to food she
admits that she's
not the most adventurous eater and she
prefers things to be kind of bland
and plain and that might explain the
repetitiveness
of some of these ingredients but i'm
just happy that i didn't hear any
explicit demonizing of foods
wellness misinformation or an obsession
with clean eating
she doesn't seem to like cut out any
food groups or
or the typically off-limit foods like
cheese and bread
and she also isn't consuming massive
bowls of lettuce
like it's her day job she just kind of
seems like she's eating what she likes
and for the most part her meals seem
pretty accessible
and simple but let's talk a little bit
about some gentle nutrition tips
first of all i would just kind of love
to see
more food throughout the day i don't
know for sure if this is olivia's
typical dietary pattern but
i don't know it seems like she eats
pretty light all day long
and then eats half of her day's calories
at dinner
so i would love to see a few more
balanced snacks
peppered throughout the day just to
ensure that she's better able to meet
her micronutrient needs for the day
and also keep her energy levels steady
so ideally we would want to be thinking
about the hunger
crushing combo and building these snacks
and meals
so that means of course a source of
fiber protein
and healthy fats so this could mean
maybe adding some
guacamole hummus or like a white bean
dip
with her veggie chips combining a couple
hard-boiled eggs with some crackers and
cheese
or making a really super quick trail mix
with nuts
seeds and dried fruit so even for days
where she doesn't feel like having
a lot of meal-like foods in the house
there's an
opportunity to get the nutrition that
she needs i would also recommend trying
to expand the variety of her diet
in a way that feels safe to her i know
she mentioned that she's picky eater so
she prefers things to be pretty plain
but we could start small by doing some
food chaining
which i know i've talked a little bit
about in my emma
chamberlain video right here so for
example
let's say she wanted to learn to like
fresh tomatoes
basically she could take like a safe
food that she likes let's say
pasta with jarred tomato sauce and then
she could maybe add some chunks of
tomato into her sauce
then she could make a sauce that's
basically just
cooked tomatoes in some oil with pasta a
la
the viral baked feta instagram recipe
and then
maybe she could do cooked cherry
tomatoes on their own
and then finally the raw tomato i'm
giving you an all tomato
meaning that you give me the whole
tomato or else that's just a really
super random example
because i know that like her father is
italian so it's possible she actually
really likes tomatoes
but variety is the spice of life so
making these tiny little efforts to swap
out the veggie
protein or carbs that she eats every few
days
may make it easier for her to meet those
micronutrient needs
so to sum it up i was kind of pleasantly
surprised by olivia's diet
not because it's particularly balanced
or healthy
but just because i actually don't think
that i really heard her talk
much about health or diet culture period
so while i do think that she may be
under eating a bit
and that her diet lacks some variety it
seems more likely to me that's
because she's kind of picky eater and
she's probably more of a
eat to live kind of person and as a
result she just isn't really that
motivated to
eat a lot more food so to me it's a bit
of a delicate balance of
trying to not over obsess about eating
and food and to also make sure that
we're still
meeting our nutrient needs by eating
enough so hopefully she can work towards
finding that balance for herself
and on that note that is all that i have
for you guys today thank you again to
buildbar for sponsoring this video
if you liked it be sure to give it the
thumbs up leave me a comment below with
who you'd like to see me review next
subscribe to the channel and i'll see
you next time on abby's kitchen
bye and for more great videos like this
check out the link right here
you